Tasha: 我们正好有一个盘子
Tasha: We just have a plate.
Tasha: 没那个然后可以把那个盘子拿来
Tasha: Without that, we can use the plate.
Tasha: 放10个蛋糕就行
Tasha: Just put 10 cakes on it.
Tasha: 对正好有个盘子刚被我们抽出来了
Tasha: Yeah, we just pulled out a plate.
Shure: 真无敌
Shure: Unbeatable.
Jake:YES
Jake:大成功
Lucia: 所以所以外面可以了是吗
Jake:嗯对
Jake:当然可以了
Jake:温度起来了
Jake:火还没完全到
Jake:可以开始烤了就是
Lucia: 我那个杯子在哪里来
Lucia: Where's my cup?
Tasha: 杯子
Tasha: Cup.
Tasha: 杯子杯子
Tasha: Cup, cup.
Lucia: 哦我怎么老是找不到东西呢
Lucia: Oh, why do I always lose things?
Katrina: 咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Lucia: 放10个
Lucia: Put 10.
Shure: 没事放那
Shure: It's okay, leave it there.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 12个也行
Tasha: 12 is fine too.
Tasha: 10个吧不知道
Tasha: Maybe 10, I don't know.
Lucia: 行万一一会到的多了再放
Lucia: Okay, if we get more later, we'll add them.
Lucia: 强迫症发作
Lucia: OCD kicking in.
Jake:我来把芒果给干掉
Jake: I'll handle the mango.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:我放在哪了找个碗
Jake: Where did I put it? Let's find a bowl.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 我住在2楼
Katrina: I live on the 2nd floor.
Shure: 微微微你50
Shure: Tasha, you get 50.
Tasha: 你可以每个里面放3块3
Tasha: You can put 3 pieces in each.
Shure: 又给你多30呢
Shure: I even gave you 30 more.
Tasha: 嗯铺个底
Tasha: Yeah, lay a base.
Katrina: 到处都有摄像头
Katrina: There are cameras everywhere.
Tasha: 我看铺个底要多少个好吧
Tasha: I think we should see how many we need to lay a base.
Katrina: 看见没有
Katrina: Did you see that?
Shure: 哪天没哪次没给你
Shure: When did I not give you?
Katrina: 就是这种
Katrina: Just like this.
Tasha: 这么多吧
Tasha: This much, right?
Tasha: 大概123 哈哈
Tasha: About 123, haha.
Katrina: 到处都是电脑
Katrina: Computers are everywhere.
Tasha: 好就铺个底就行这样子
Tasha: Alright, just lay a base like this.
Tasha: 9-10个吧
Tasha: About 9-10.
Lucia: 行好嘞
Lucia: Got it.
Shure: 你还是先把他这么侧着吧
Shure: You should just tilt it like this first.
Tasha: 要不来倒主厨
Tasha: How about we let the head chef do it?
Jake:哈哈我
Jake: Haha, me?
Jake:我怎么敢
Jake: How could I dare?
Jake:哎倒什么呀
Jake: Hey, what are we pouring?
Tasha: 就把它倒进去就行
Tasha: Just pour it in, that's all.
Jake:好好行
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 倒个七八分满就行
Tasha: Just fill it about seven or eight tenths full.
Tasha: 但是要 12个
Tasha: But we need 12 of them.
Jake:三分之
Jake: One-third...
Tasha: 你要倒均匀点吗
Tasha: Do you want to pour it evenly?
Lucia: 咦多了
Lucia: Oops, too much.
Jake:好那我就慢慢倒
Jake: Alright, I'll pour slowly then.
Tasha: 不着急要等这个烤出来他才能到
Tasha: No rush, we have to wait for this to bake before we can pour the next batch.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, oh.
Tasha: 他才能进
Tasha: Then it can go in.
Tasha: 进下一锅
Tasha: Into the next batch.
Jake:懂了
Jake: Got it.
Jake:那我还是干芒果
Jake: Then I'll stick with the mango.
Jake:这芒果不软的
Jake: This mango isn't soft.
Tasha: 虽然不软
Tasha: Although it's not soft,
Tasha: 但是我感觉它看起来有啊
Tasha: I feel like it looks okay.
Tasha: 好像已经有点
Tasha: It seems a bit...
Lucia: 稍微有点那个氧化了一样
Lucia: A little bit oxidized, maybe.
Jake:有水果刀吗
Jake: Do we have a fruit knife?
Jake:用菜刀也行吧
Jake: A kitchen knife will do, right?
Tasha: 嗯要求不要太过分
Tasha: Yeah, just don't be too picky.
Jake:这不过分吧
Jake: This isn't too picky, right?
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: Pretty much.
Tasha: 进入完全不讲究状态
Tasha: We're entering the 'don't care' mode.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 他只有那边那根能点着
Shure: Only that one over there can be lit.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 咖啡豆啊
Katrina: Coffee beans, huh?
Shure: 因为风是往那边吹所以点不着
Shure: The wind's blowing that way, so it won't light.
Tasha: 呃巧克力
Tasha: Uh, chocolate.
Katrina: 巧克力啊没事不用对不起
Lucia: 可以吃一个吗哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Can I have one? Hahaha.
Tasha: 可以啊他就是纯巧克力黑巧58
Tasha: Sure, it's pure dark chocolate, 58%.
Lucia: 要先吃一片吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Do you want to have a piece first? Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈我不要
Tasha: Haha, no, I don't want to.
Lucia: 宇轩要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want to have a piece first?
Lucia: 健康要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Jiankang, do you want to have a piece first?
Jake:好好
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 我就不喂你了
Lucia: I'm not going to feed you.
Lucia: 自己可以给你倒出来哈哈
Lucia: You can serve yourself. Haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哎呀我再来一片
Lucia: Oh, I'll have another piece.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:这叫什么呀
Jake: What's it called?
Tasha: 一定要认准这个牌子
Tasha: You have to recognize this brand.
Tasha: 百丽
Tasha: Belle.
Tasha: 天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 哈哈哈他突然文盲哈哈哈哈不不不
Lucia: Hahaha, suddenly he's illiterate. Hahaha, no, no, no.
Tasha: 不愧是高材生
Tasha: As expected of a top student.
Tasha: 说话就是这么有水平
Tasha: He speaks so well.
Alice:有这么厚
Alice: It's this thick.
Alice:有这么薄呢
Alice: Or this thin.
Tasha: 我来切吧
Tasha: I'll cut it.
Tasha: 你去忙那个
Tasha: You go do that.
Tasha: 好我先跟你
Tasha: Okay, let me first...
Tasha: 你菜板忙
Tasha: ...get you a cutting board.
Tasha: 洗了吗怎么感觉这么脏
Tasha: Did you wash it? Why does it feel so dirty?
Jake:加点洋葱味问题不大
Jake: Adding a bit of onion flavor, no big deal.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这菜板怎么这么脏啊
Tasha: Hahaha, why is this cutting board so dirty?
Katrina: 哇噻哇噻哇噻
Katrina: Wow, wow, wow.
Jake:这菜板怎么这么脏啊
Jake: Why is this cutting board so dirty?
Tasha: 你这菜刀洗了吗
Tasha: Did you wash this knife?
Jake:菜刀洗了
Jake: The knife is washed.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:板是蒜和洋葱
Jake: The board has garlic and onions.
Shure: 给你补个光哎
Shure: Let me give you some extra light.
Jake:对哇不要蒜
Jake: Yeah, no garlic.
Lucia: 哇不要蒜
Lucia: Wow, no garlic.
Lucia: 蒜沾到水果上面味道很大的
Lucia: If garlic touches the fruit, the smell is really strong.
Lucia: 洋葱可能还好一点
Lucia: Onions might be okay.
Tasha: 你太过分了
Tasha: You're too much.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 把水果也从洗了
Tasha: Also wash the fruit.
Jake:好好水果我也洗一洗
Jake: Okay, I'll wash the fruit too.
Lucia: 没事幸好它还没切开
Lucia: It’s fine, luckily it hasn’t been cut yet.
Lucia: 要蒜味要沾到水果上真的特别难消掉
Lucia: If the garlic smell gets on the fruit, it’s really hard to get rid of.
Lucia: 就是你就会吃到那个味道
Lucia: You’ll definitely taste it.
Lucia: 就是葱不是葱
Lucia: It’s like, onions... no, not onions.
Lucia: 蒜瓣西瓜吃过吗
Lucia: Have you ever had garlic-flavored watermelon?
Lucia: 哈哈哈蒜瓣西瓜对我
Lucia: Haha, garlic-flavored watermelon, seriously.
Jake:蒜瓣西瓜就是把蒜给绞西瓜汁里
Jake: Garlic-flavored watermelon is when you mix garlic into the watermelon juice.
Lucia: 没有就有一回
Lucia: No, it just happened once.
Tasha: 就是切切的刀上面有蒜味
Tasha: It’s like when the knife you used has garlic on it.
Lucia: 我们家里忘记对我们家切过蒜的刀
Lucia: At home, we forgot and used a knife that had cut garlic.
Jake:哦哦切刀刀上哦
Jake: Oh, the knife had garlic on it.
Lucia: 忘记了然后直接切的瓜
Lucia: We forgot and cut the watermelon with it.
Lucia: 然后那个味道特别可怕
Lucia: And the taste was really awful.
Jake:用什么东西泡呀
Jake: What do you soak it with?
Tasha: 这肉
Tasha: This meat.
Shure: 他也整不着整半天
Shure: He can't get it right after so long.
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You do it.
Tasha: 这个可以
Tasha: This one is okay.
Tasha: 您要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Jake:我可以要
Jake: I can take it.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 就他可以
Tasha: He can do it.
Tasha: 阻断他流
Tasha: Stop him from flowing.
Lucia: 生菜确实一般
Lucia: Lettuce is really just average.
Lucia: 可能都直接在这放一下好了
Lucia: Maybe we should just put it here for a while.
Tasha: 好凝视
Tasha: Alright, focus.
Lucia: 哎小心吃会不会那个会不会烫
Lucia: Hey, be careful, will it be too hot?
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 咱要不把它
Lucia: Why don't we
Lucia: 都掰开吧
Lucia: Break it all apart?
Tasha: 不听
Tasha: Not listening.
Katrina: 嗯应该是掰开了
Katrina: Yeah, it should be broken apart.
Katrina: 然后一片片水洗一下冲一下
Katrina: Then rinse each piece with water.
Shure: 怎么不把他
Shure: Why don't you
Shure: 那个最红的那边冲上呢
Shure: Rinse the reddest part?
Lucia: 找个盘子
Lucia: Get a plate.
Katrina: 然后还要干嘛来着
Katrina: What else do we need?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Katrina: 哦还要拿两个杯子
Katrina: Oh, and we need two cups.
Shure: 你怎么没把他最红的那边冲上
Shure: Why didn't you rinse the reddest part?
Jake:是不是有点太保守了
Jake: Is it a bit too conservative?
Lucia: 把盘拿大点的
Lucia: Get a bigger plate.
Lucia: 盘子这盘
Lucia: This plate, this one.
Lucia: 不过这盘子还没用过
Lucia: But this plate hasn't been used.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then
Jake:我先少弄点啊
Jake: I'll just use a little bit first.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Jake:好我保守一点保守一点
Jake: Alright, I'll be more conservative.
Lucia: 就它吧
Lucia: Let's use this one.
Shure: 同仁堂开的
Shure: Made by Tong Ren Tang.
Lucia: 啊那这又要再放一下先
Lucia: Ah, then let's put this aside for now.
Tasha: 这个有点多了吧
Tasha: Isn't this a bit much?
Tasha: 不是很保守吗
Tasha: Isn't it supposed to be conservative?
Lucia: 这怎么搞
Lucia: How do we do this?
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Jake:这个多吗
Jake: Is this too much?
Tasha: 这正常吧
Tasha: This is normal, right?
Tasha: 我觉最高就这么高就行了
Tasha: I think this height is just right.
Shure: 草那个该翻个面
Shure: Hey, it should be flipped.
Jake:保守一点保守一点
Jake: More conservative, more conservative.
Jake:太吵了哎
Jake: Too noisy, hey.
Jake:保守一点保守一点
Jake: More conservative, more conservative.
Jake:诶诶诶诶诶诶别
Jake: Hey hey hey, don't.
Shure: 这没个灯真不行
Shure: It's really hard without a light.
Jake:别动啊别动啊诶
Jake: Don't move, don't move, hey.
Jake:我可能会了
Jake: I think I got it.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 有合关发牌
Tasha: There's a deal with the cards.
Tasha: 有杨老师在线切蛋糕液
Tasha: And Jake is cutting the cake online.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿是吧
Tasha: Hehe, right?
Jake:对哎感觉不错
Jake: Yeah, it feels pretty good.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:挺好玩
Jake: It's fun.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好玩多玩会
Tasha: Let's play more.
Tasha: 哎这个会不会太过分了
Tasha: Hey, isn't this a bit too much?
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:我怕最后不够了
Jake: I'm afraid we might run out at the end.
Lucia: 你干了什么
Lucia: What did you do?
Jake:还好还好就是呃呃尽量让他均匀
Jake: It's alright, just trying to make it even.
Tasha: 尽量让他均匀
Tasha: Trying to make it even.
Jake:但是可能没那么均匀
Jake: But it might not be that even.
Tasha: 你看第一个和这个均匀吗
Tasha: Look, is the first one even?
Jake:哎一会再补一补啊补一补
Jake: Hey, we'll fix it, fix it.
Lucia: 你做了什么伤天害理的事
Lucia: What horrible thing did you do?
Jake:补一补补一补
Jake: We'll fix it, fix it.
Jake:就是这个分配不均
Jake: It's just uneven distribution.
Tasha: 这个这个这个
Tasha: This, this, this.
Jake:这个哈哈哈
Jake: This, haha.
Tasha: 不患寡患不均
Tasha: It's not about scarcity, it's about unevenness.
Lucia: 不患寡而患不均
Lucia: It's not about scarcity, it's about unevenness.
Jake:对就是现在这既既寡又不均
Jake: Yeah, now it's both scarce and uneven.
Katrina: 有多的镊子吗
Katrina: Do you have extra tweezers?
Lucia: 弃寡又不均
Lucia: Scarce and uneven.
Katrina: 要我帮你吗
Katrina: Need my help?
Tasha: 这个放在烤箱面前
Tasha: Put this in front of the oven.
Tasha: 会不会把它水分给烤了
Tasha: Won't it dry out the moisture?
Lucia: 我刚也在这么想
Lucia: I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 但是我好像暂时没找到别的地方
Lucia: But I can't find another place.
Lucia: 我打算快点洗
Lucia: I'll try to wash it quickly.
Tasha: 这个厨房就这么小对
Tasha: The kitchen is just this small, right.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 咱们人比较多
Lucia: We have quite a few people here.
Lucia: 这厨房有点太小了
Lucia: This kitchen is a bit too small.
Lucia: 这么大厨房我觉得两三个人还行
Lucia: For a kitchen this size, two or three people would be fine.
Lucia: 再多就东西会放不下
Lucia: Any more and we won't have enough space.
Tasha: 还有十几分钟这我就烤好了
Tasha: In about ten minutes, this will be done baking.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 那咱外面的进度咋样
Lucia: So how's the progress outside?
Jake:呃进度
Jake: Uh, progress...
Jake:不知道啊反正5分钟之前进度是0
Jake: I don't know, but five minutes ago, progress was at zero.
Lucia: 说明他们进度与指数函数性增长
Lucia: That means their progress is growing exponentially.
Jake:是的是是这么回事
Jake: Yeah, that's how it is.
Jake:是一个呃
Jake: It's, uh...
Tasha: 维护秀是吧
Tasha: Maintenance show, right?
Shure: 把盖把把盖拔下来
Shure: Just take off the cover.
Jake:应该就是就火点着了
Jake: It should ignite the fire.
Jake:然后就可以开始了
Jake: Then we can start.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Tasha: OK火点着了
Tasha: Okay, the fire is lit.
Lucia: 火点着这是个原爆点
Lucia: The fire's lit, this is ground zero.
Tasha: 是个原爆点是的
Tasha: Yep, it's ground zero.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 谁会成为我们的普罗米修斯呢
Lucia: Who's going to be our Prometheus?
Jake:是
Jake: Yep.
Jake:刚刚特意买了一个
Jake: I just bought one especially.
Jake:就是一瓶酒精然后全撒上去了没有用
Jake: It was a bottle of alcohol, poured it all over, didn't work.
Jake:那个碳比较难点
Jake: The charcoal's hard to light.
Jake:碳质量一般
Jake: The quality of the charcoal is so-so.
Katrina: 应该用那种蜂窝
Katrina: We should use that honeycomb kind.
Katrina: 蜂窝的那个
Katrina: The honeycomb one.
Jake:应该是
Jake: Probably.
Lucia: 它接触氧的面积会比较大一点
Lucia: It has more surface area to contact with oxygen.
Katrina: 耶
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 只剩一只筷子了
Katrina: There's jus
Jake:听起来是这样
Jake:一只筷子
Alice:一开始烤
Katrina: 哎我们只有这几双筷子
Jake:我也好奇那个他什么情况
Alice:有希望能熟反正
Alice: There's hope it will be ripe anyway.
Lucia: 哎还行吧
Lucia: Yeah, it's alright.
Jake:对啊可好了
Jake: Yeah, it's pretty good.
Tasha: 你是刚才就是再分配了一下吗
Tasha: Did you just redistribute it?
Jake:对对对再分配
Jake: Yes, yes, redistributed.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 二次分配
Tasha: Redistribution.
Jake:哈哈哈是的
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:就和谐了嘛
Jake: Now it's harmonious.
Jake:现在很和谐
Jake: Very harmonious now.
Jake:扶贫现在是
Jake: Poverty alleviation now.
Jake:看看好现在全面脱贫
Jake: Look, now total poverty eradication.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈可以吧
Jake: Hahaha, not bad, right?
Lucia: 好家伙
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:怎么样和谐
Jake: How's the harmony?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good.
Lucia: 可以非常好
Lucia: It's great, very good.
Tasha: 你看有的很好
Tasha: Look, some are really good.
Jake:啊还是有一些先富的人是吧
Jake: Ah, still some people get rich first, right?
Katrina: 了
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 哎我觉得里面的这些叶子很干净
Lucia: Hey, I think the leaves inside are very clean.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 不是你看这上面有很多气泡看到了吗
Tasha: No, look, there are many bubbles on it, see?
Tasha: 啊就这样子
Tasha: Ah, just like this.
Jake:哦那我每个都打一会
Jake: Oh, then I'll hit each one for a while.
Tasha: 就是因为你可能弄得太低了
Tasha: It's because you probably made it too low.
Tasha: 然后他的气泡就会产生
Tasha: Then bubbles will form.
Tasha: 这样子会导致他很多空心的就不太
Tasha: This will cause a lot of hollow ones, which is not good.
Jake:就不太明白哎
Jake: I don't quite get it, hey.
Tasha: 哎这个
Tasha: Hey, this...
Jake:这个这怎么了
Jake: What's up with this?
Jake:这太少了啊
Jake: This is too little.
Tasha: 啊没事
Tasha: Ah, it's okay.
Jake:没事还是有低保户
Jake: It's okay, still some low-income households.
Tasha: 嗯对你把有气泡的就这样子震一震
Tasha: Yeah, just shake the ones with bubbles like this.
Lucia: 什么历史遗留问题是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: What historical issues, right? Hahaha. 社会问题
Jake:哈哈哈对是地质疑的问题
Jake: Hahaha, yes, geological issues.
Tasha: 不然不然它不好吃就不够松软
Tasha: Otherwise, if it's not good, it won't be soft and fluffy.
Jake:哦我每个都摔一摔吧
Jake: Oh, I'll give each of them a shake.
Jake:嗯那这个我怎么加上呢
Jake: Hmm, how should I add this?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:就有一个小的是吧
Jake: There's a small one, right?
Tasha: 算了吧
Tasha: Forget it.
Tasha: 中国总有贫困地区的
Tasha: There are always poor areas in China. 社会问题
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 要遵循事物的发展规律吗
Lucia: Should we follow the natural development of things?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 这个还要再洗一下
Tasha: This needs to be washed again.
Lucia: 哈怎么了
Lucia: Haha, what's up?
Lucia: 你以为我个人专业
Lucia: You think I'm a professional?
Jake:哈哈哈专业太专业了
Jake: Haha, too professional.
Lucia: 个人简历的专业是白写的哈
Lucia: My resume's professional experience was written in vain, huh?
Jake:这个你要不写个报告吧
Jake: Why don't you write a report on this?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:哈哈怎么了
Jake: Haha, what's up?
Tasha: 没事没事没事
Tasha: It's nothing, it's nothing.
Jake:撒了
Jake: It spilled.
Tasha: 等会再用
Tasha: We'll use it later.
Tasha: 这部分谁都不要碰
Tasha: Nobody touch this part.
Jake:那谁敢碰啊
Jake: Who would dare touch it?
Lucia: 这玩意我先给他们端出去吧
Lucia: Let me take this out to them first.
Lucia: 要出去吗
Lucia: Should I take it out?
Lucia: 来看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Lucia: 别别菜叶子吹干了
Lucia: Don't let the vegetable leaves dry out.
Tasha: 干什么呢干什么呢干什么呢
Tasha: What are you doing, what are you doing?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 我要干嘛
Tasha: What am I doing?
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:你要干嘛你要干嘛
Jake: What are you doing, what are you doing?
Lucia: 这个菜现在用得到吗
Lucia: Do we need this dish now?
Lucia: 如果暂时用不到我就先放回去
Lucia: If not, I'll put it back for now.
Tasha: 你怎么这么凶
Tasha: Why are you so fierce?
Lucia: 一会再拿出来
Lucia: We'll take it out later.
Jake:你要干嘛啊
Tasha: 哈哈哈你要不就切芒果吧别再摔了
Tasha: Hahaha, why don't you cut the mango instead, stop shaking it.
Jake:哈哈哈对不起对不起
Jake: Hahaha, sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 桌上我怕外面灰大一会就
Lucia: I'm afraid the dust from outside will get on the table.
Jake:为啥可以了
Jake: Why is it okay now?
Tasha: 好了可以了哈哈哈
Tasha: It's fine now, hahaha.
Jake:我挺喜欢摔的
Jake: I actually like smashing it.
Jake:因为里面有一些气泡
Jake: Because there are some bubbles inside.
Jake:他还需要我
Jake: He still needs me.
Tasha: 他需要你好
Tasha: He needs you, okay.
Jake:他还需要我
Jake: He still needs me.
Jake:对他还需要
Jake: Yeah, he still needs me.
Jake:我我觉得我还可以
Jake: I feel like I'm still useful.
Jake:有贡献的地方他还需要我
Jake: There's something I can contribute, he still needs me.
Lucia: 那煤能给它敲碎吗
Lucia: Can the coal be smashed into pieces?
Lucia: 我感觉那么大一块确实不太不太好
Lucia: I feel like it's too big to handle properly.
Tasha: 哎我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 那啥
Lucia: What?
Jake:不能这么干是吧
Jake: We can't do it like this, right?
Tasha: 呃没必要
Tasha: Uh, no need.
Jake:哦好行
Jake: Oh, okay, sure.
Tasha: 可以了可以了
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 干嘛呢接下来
Tasha: What are we doing next?
Jake:不不有气泡
Jake: No, no, there are bubbles.
Tasha: 去切去
Tasha: Go cut it.
Jake:真有气泡
Jake: There are really bubbles.
Tasha: 真没必要了
Tasha: It's really not necessary.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈这为什么感觉有
Jake: Haha, why does it feel like there are
Jake:有红的颜色
Jake: some red colors?
Jake:是这个油
Jake: Is it this oil?
Tasha: 巧克力可能溶溶了一些可以了
Tasha: Maybe the chocolate melted a bit, it's okay.
Jake:你看这个是气泡吧
Jake: Look, this is a bubble, right?
Lucia: 这哪里有红的
Lucia: Where is it red?
Lucia: 您绝对色感也太好了吧
Lucia: Your color perception is amazing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈有这种夸赞吗
Jake: Hahaha, is that even a compliment?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你是不是想说这么明显
Lucia: Hahaha, are you trying to say it's so obvious?
Lucia: 哈哈哈是啊
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake:不是不是我说有这种夸赞
Jake: No, no, I mean, is that even a compliment?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:不是就是
Jake: No, I mean...
Lucia: 真是一种夸赞
Lucia: It's really a compliment.
Lucia: 你学画画很厉害的
Lucia: You're really good at art.
Lucia: 会哈哈哈
Lucia: Sure, hahaha.
Jake:好这么回事
Jake: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:可能是我这个眼线的反射
Jake: Maybe it's the reflection from my eyeliner.
Jake:我怎么切怎么切
Jake: How do I cut this, how do I cut this?
Tasha: 怎么切直直接切就行
Tasha: Just cut it straight, it'll be fine.
Jake:好我就切
Jake: Okay, I'll cut.
Jake:行我直接切
Jake: Alright, I'll just cut it straight.
Lucia: 另外这棵菜哎呀
Lucia: And this other vegetable, oh my...
Lucia: 我都在想要不等他们进度再再来点
Lucia: I was thinking, should we wait for their progress a bit and then add more?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我再洗
Lucia: I'll wash it again.
Jake:楼上其实可以整整俩整板下来
Jake: Actually, we can bring down two whole boards from upstairs.
Lucia: 菜这东西
Lucia: As for vegetables...
Jake:但是还没必要
Jake: But it's not really necessary yet.
Lucia: 如果洗了就不能就不太能放了
Lucia: Once you wash them, you can't really store them.
Lucia: 万一是吧
Lucia: Just in case, you know?
Lucia: 我们退一万步讲
Lucia: Let's assume the worst-case scenario.
Jake:对万一今天他就打不着了哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, what if today we can't even light the fire, hahaha.
Lucia: 今天晚对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, tonight, haha.
Jake:退一百步就是哈哈哈
Jake: Even if we take a hundred steps back, haha.
Tasha: 我买的我买的
Tasha: I bought it, I bought it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 烤箱温度计
Tasha: The oven thermometer.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my!
Tasha: 竟然真的是
Tasha: I can't believe it actually is.
Lucia: 这个是不是要洗啊这个对对对
Lucia: Does this need to be washed? Yes, it does, right?
Tasha: 不是要洗啊
Tasha: Doesn't it need to be washed?
Tasha: 是吗对对对
Tasha: Right? Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 虽然很危险
Tasha: Although it's very dangerous.
Lucia: 哎呀就喜欢这种没有油的东西
Lucia: Oh, I love this oil-free stuff.
Lucia: 一旦沾上油就可难洗老难洗
Lucia: Once it gets greasy, it's so hard to clean.
Lucia: 我靠我不会又弄衣服了吧
Lucia: Oh man, I hope I didn't get my clothes dirty again.
Jake:我感觉好像不
Jake: I don't think so.
Jake:好像切了出来怎么没什么肉啊
Jake: It seems like there's not much meat when I cut it.
Lucia: 因为皮上沾的太多了
Lucia: Because a lot is stuck to the skin.
Shure: 炭烧透了
Shure: The charcoal is well done.
Jake:我来
Jake: Let me try.
Tasha: 给你们洗个碟
Jake:我来我来研究研究
Jake: I'll take a look at this.
Lucia: 不是您这个的正确打开方法
Lucia: That's not the right way to open it.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 哎sorry啊
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Tasha: 不用sorry吧
Tasha: No need to say sorry.
Tasha: 给您洗个碟
Tasha: Let me wash a dish for you.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 您想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: Cut it however you want.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 你这个的正确打开方式
Lucia: This is the correct way to open it.
Lucia: 现在变成了这样
Lucia: Now it's like this.
Tasha: 不是这个里面没盒吗
Tasha: Isn't there no box inside?
Lucia: 我给你我给你演示一下啊哈哈
Lucia: Let me show you, haha.
Jake:有有有还没搞定呢试一下啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it's not done yet. Let's try it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈好很正确
Jake: Hahaha, alright, that's correct.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈你知道吗
Lucia: Haha, you know what?
Jake:哈哈哈我也来正确一下
Jake: Hahaha, let me do it the right way too.
Lucia: 打开包成了这样的
Lucia: It turned out like this when I opened the package.
Jake:好好好会了会了我也会了
Jake: Alright, alright, I get it now, I can do it too.
Tasha: 我也会的
Tasha: I can do it too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 这个应该不是你切的问题
Lucia: This probably isn't a cutting issue.
Tasha: 就有的芒果它就是皮比较容易粘肉
Tasha: Some mangoes have skins that tend to stick to the flesh.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:就应该这么打开
Jake: This is how it should be opened.
Shure: 也有可能是这个碳太低了
Shure: It might also be that the carbon is too low.
Lucia: 对秉承着我们不浪费的原则
Lucia: Right, sticking to our principle of not wasting.
Lucia: 就也可以先这样吃一下
Lucia: We can just eat it like this.
Lucia: 然后那部分的用来用来当馅
Lucia: And then use that part as filling.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Sounds good.
Lucia: 外面是不是有什么进展了
Lucia: Is there any progress outside?
Lucia: 我好像听见了碗筷的声音
Lucia: I think I heard the sound of dishes.
Lucia:   哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 给孩子饿成啥了
Tasha: The kids must be starving.
Jake:在敲是吧
Jake: Are they knocking?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 他们可能只是单纯的就是在把碗筷
Lucia: They might just be setting the table.
Jake:走位哈哈哈接
Jake: Move, haha, keep going.
Lucia: 哈哈哈从一个地方搬到另一个地方
Lucia: Haha, moving from one place to another.
Jake:好吧好吧虽然打不着继续走位
Jake: Alright, alright, even though we can't hit it, keep moving.
Jake:接着走位
Jake: Keep moving.
Tasha: 他就烤好了
Tasha: It's done cooking.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Lucia: 我当时想问能不能把那个碳
Lucia: I was wondering if we could...
Lucia: 比如说怎么着给它敲
Lucia: Maybe we could break the charcoal...
Lucia: 敲碎一点
Lucia: into smaller pieces?
Jake:不要切到手呀
Jake: Don't cut your hand.
Jake:那我这个会这个知道
Jake: I know how to do this.
Jake:这个多少知道一点
Jake: I know a little bit about this.
Tasha: 您真的不用争取用一下碘伏了
Tasha: You really don't need to use iodine.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不用争取
Lucia: Haha, you don't need to insist.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈我尽力
Jake: Haha, I'll try my best.
Lucia: 这真不用争取
Lucia: You really don't need to insist.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 您争取不用
Lucia: Don't insist.
Jake:好争取不用
Jake: Okay, I won't insist.
Jake:这怎么下来
Jake: How do we get this down?
Tasha: 杨老师你把这盘弄这么脏
Tasha: Jake, you made this tray so dirty.
Jake:哎
Jake: Huh?
Jake:啊哪个盘啊对不起
Jake: Ah, which tray? Sorry.
Lucia: 烤箱盘
Lucia: The oven tray.
Tasha: 拿个纸吧
Tasha: Get a paper towel.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 这个干净的
Lucia: This one is clean.
Lucia: 我刚只是冲了手的时候擦了一下水
Lucia: I just wiped my hands with it after washing.
Lucia: 哎这为啥有
Lucia: Hey, why is there...
Lucia: 一个撒了的
Lucia: some spilled stuff?
Tasha: 呃不要碰
Tasha: Uh, don't touch it.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 等会我们还要弄进去
Tasha: We'll need it later.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这是干净的
Tasha: Haha, this one is clean.
Shure: 一会差不多算着了
Shure: It'll be ready soon.
Lucia: 好的好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 还还差纸还差纸
Tasha: We still need paper, we still need paper.
Lucia: 擦盘子是吧
Lucia: To wipe the plates, right?
Lucia: 反正是那就用昨天肯德基还是啥
Lucia: Anyway, just use the paper from yesterday's KFC or something.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 这纸这纸
Lucia: This paper, this paper.
Lucia: 为啥是这样
Lucia: Why is it like this?
Lucia: 有点太脏了
Lucia: It's a bit too dirty.
Alice:着了
Alice: Got it.
Lucia: 叮咚
Lucia: Ding dong.
Tasha: 主要这个烤盘烤箱不是借的吗
Tasha: The main thing is this baking tray and oven, aren't they borrowed?
Shure: 还有
Shure: And also...
Tasha: 啊环的时候要是烤的这么
Tasha: If we bake it like this...
Tasha: 就是都粘在这上面了
Tasha: Everything will stick to it.
Tasha: 就烤完之后就不好清理了对
Tasha: It will be hard to clean after baking, right?
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: That's it.
Shure: 哦那牛排没腌卧槽
Shure: Oh no, the steak isn't marinated!
Jake:再来一个
Jake: Let's do another one.
Jake:哎哪去了
Jake: Hey, where did it go?
Lucia: 这是几个切出来的呀
Lucia: How many pieces did you cut out?
Jake:这是一个切出来的
Jake: This is from one piece.
Lucia: 那还行那还行
Lucia: That's okay then.
Lucia: 我以为是俩呢
Lucia: I thought it was two pieces.
Jake:哈哈哈被吃的太多了
Jake: Hahaha, it's been eaten too much.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈没关系继续吃
Jake: Hahaha, it's alright, keep eating.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:准备好了吗
Jake: Are you ready?
Jake:准备吃啊
Jake: Ready to eat?
Tasha: OK还挺准的呢
Tasha: OK, it's quite accurate.
Tasha: 这个温度
Tasha: This temperature.
Lucia: 薇薇可以吃芒果了
Lucia: Tasha, you can eat mango now.
Tasha: 不是你一个芒果就算切出这么多
Tasha: Didn't you cut out that much from one mango?
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我以为是两个切的呢
Tasha: I thought it was from two mangoes.
Tasha: 我还想挺不错的呢
Tasha: I was thinking it's quite good.
Lucia: 哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, alright.
Jake:好那那我再切一个
Jake: Okay, then I'll cut another one.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 毕竟刚才那个皮上沾了很多
Lucia: After all, the skin had a lot stuck to it earlier.
Jake:这个皮上应该也沾不少
Jake: There should be quite a bit stuck on the peel too.
Lucia: 如果有水果刀可以那样削着皮切
Lucia: If we had a fruit knife, we could peel and cut like that.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Tasha: 但是咱家没有
Tasha: But we don't have one at home.
Tasha: 我们不是有个削皮刀吗
Tasha: Don't we have a peeler?
Lucia: 小心手
Lucia: Be careful with your hand.
Tasha: 好像不行
Tasha: Seems like it won't work.
Lucia: 削对
Lucia: Peel it right.
Lucia: 削一套好
Lucia: Peel a set properly.
Tasha: 什么手法秘制
Tasha: What kind of secret technique is that?
Jake:这个就是
Jake: That's exactly it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 辣椒面是
Tasha: Is this chili powder?
Tasha: 不知道拿去
Tasha: Not sure where to put it.
Lucia: 呃外面吗
Lucia: Uh, outside?
Lucia: 也行我先给他们拿过去吧
Lucia: Maybe, I'll take it to them first.
Tasha: 哎这还有个孜然
Tasha: Hey, there's also cumin here.
Tasha: 这什么东西啊芝麻
Tasha: What's this? Sesame?
Lucia: 芝麻哎呀
Lucia: Sesame, oh dear.
Lucia: 拿过去吧
Lucia: Take it over.
Lucia: 看能不能用着
Lucia: See if they can use it.
Tasha: 这个地方等会要放蛋糕
Tasha: This spot is for the cake later.
Tasha: 你旁边那个架子
Tasha: The shelf next to you.
Lucia: 有什么新的进展吗
Lucia: Any new developments?
Lucia: 这个辣椒面和那个芝麻
Lucia: This chili powder and that sesame.
Lucia: 如果需要撒的话
Lucia: If you need to sprinkle it.
Lucia: 啊他不是有那个影影
Lucia: Ah, doesn't he have that image...
Tasha: 给你讲个恐怖故事
Tasha: Let me tell you a scary story.
Lucia: 影楼影城
Lucia: Studio, movie set...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不是影楼影棚灯吗
Lucia: Isn't it the studio lighting?
Tasha: 我哥他以前就是切西瓜
Tasha: My brother used to cut watermelons.
Tasha: 然后西瓜跟着走了
Tasha: Then the watermelon went away.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 他的手也跟着走
Tasha: And his hand went with it.
Tasha: 然后他把他的手砍下来了
Tasha: Then he chopped off his hand.
Lucia: 从里边拉个插板过来
Lucia: Pull an extension cord from inside.
Jake:啊为什么
Jake: Huh, why?
Lucia: 但是拉板不是插板可能
Lucia: But a cable isn't really an extension cord.
Tasha: 就是他想砍西瓜的时候
Tasha: So when he was trying to cut the watermelon
Lucia: 没那么长
Lucia: It wasn't that long
Tasha: 然后西瓜滚了一点
Tasha: Then the watermelon rolled a bit
Tasha: 然后他的手也跟着滚了一点
Tasha: And his hand rolled with it
Lucia: 我看看啊
Lucia: Let me see
Jake:然后呢手没了
Jake: And then, the hand was gone
Tasha: 手就切下来了
Tasha: The hand got cut off
Jake:就切下来了
Jake: It got cut off
Lucia: 这地方这地方的店算了
Lucia: This place, this place's shop, forget it
Jake:就整个手嘛
Jake: The whole hand
Tasha: 后来又用什么线切回去
Tasha: Later, they used some kind of thread to sew it back
Tasha: 所以我对于切这个东西很很恐惧
Tasha: So I'm really scared of cutting things
Katrina: 英雄终于有用武之地了
Katrina: Finally, a hero has a use
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Jake:确实有用吗
Jake: Is it really useful?
Tasha: 有用
Tasha: It is
Jake:这个接回去
Jake: This can be reattached
Lucia: 烧烤组说能整个灯不
Lucia: The BBQ team said, can we get a light?
Tasha: 烧烤组
Tasha: BBQ team
Lucia: 因为外面有点暗
Lucia: Because it's a bit dark outside
Lucia: 他们现在就是在打着手电筒看
Lucia: They're using flashlights to see
Lucia: 那个就是烤箱里面的
Lucia: Inside the oven
Shure: 那牛排
Shure: The steak
Lucia: 不是烤箱烤炉里面的情况
Lucia: Not the oven, the grill's situation
Jake:我想想
Jake: Let me think
Lucia: 但是我感觉
Lucia: But I feel
Lucia: 咱们这个插对一个插板也不够长
Lucia: Even if we plug into an extension cord, it's not long enough
Jake:电线弄不出去
Jake: The wire can't reach out
Lucia: 哪怕真有一个空了的话
Lucia: Even if there is an empty one
Jake:没电
Jake: No power
Tasha: 那个支架
Tasha: That stand
Tasha: 能不能把手电筒放上面会不会好点
Tasha: Can we put the flashlight on top? Would that be better?
Tasha: 就不用举着了
Tasha: So we don't have to hold it
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia: 把那个手机固定到云台或者什么上面
Lucia: Fix the phone on a stabilizer or something
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right
Lucia: 有有有有手机夹子或者啥的
Lucia: There's a phone clip or something
Lucia: 这有个看起来有点像能夹手机的东西
Lucia: This looks like something that can hold a phone
Jake:可以啊那我就觉得呢
Jake: Sure, then I think
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure
Lucia: 但我不太确定它具体是个啥这个
Lucia: But I'm not really sure what exactly it is.
Tasha: 没关系哈哈
Tasha: It's okay, haha.
Jake:我在乡下
Jake: I'm in the countryside.